and welcome to the weekend everyone I'm
Anthony Mason along with Michelle Miller
and Elaine Quijano who's in for Dana
Jacobson happy Labor Day weekend all we
made it through the summer absolutely
incredible we begin with with this
morning services at the National
Cathedral for Senator John McCain late
last night members of the public
continued to stream through the Capitol
Rotunda to say goodbye to one of the
nation's most revered public servants
Nancy Cordes is at the National
Cathedral in Washington where two former
presidents will deliver eulogies for the
senator in just a few hours Nancy good
morning good morning
those two former presidents Barack Obama
and George W Bush and McCain's request
that the two men who beat him for the
presidency be the ones to eulogize him
was a final act of bipartisanship and
unity from the Arizona senator who
became just the 31st dignitary to lion
state at the US Capitol last night a
somber respectful and at times emotional
crowd filed through the Capitol Rotunda
Friday to say goodbye to Senator John
McCain he did a lot more than fellow
veteran Rudy Gartner came from
Alexandria Virginia his honest who did
what said he was going to do
he may have fought with other guys but
we had a good chance to come back and
apologize former colleagues and friends
like Ohio Governor John Kasich flew in
from all over the country
Texas Republican Sam Johnson who like
McCain spent time as a prisoner of war
in Vietnam stepped off the scooter he
normally relies on to join hands with
Democrat Nancy Pelosi and pay his
respects heavens opening up Friday
morning as John McCain scaled the steps
of the US Capitol for the last time we
give thanks for the consequential life
of Senator John McCain a drum major for
courage truth and justice the rare honor
of lying in state was extended by the
leaders of both parties who marveled
that the Senators seemingly limitless
energy and a day like this John would
usually be bounding this way or that way
right through here visitors turning to
each other asking if that's who they
think it is despite serious war wounds
and multiple battles with cancer McCain
spent 35 years fighting to change the
status quo on issues like torture
immigration and government waste I don't
know what the deal was but we'll find
out what the deal was just like the
deals were College is full of lobbyists
airing our great debates is the gentle
way to describe how John approached the
work of a Senator oblong joked that his
guards at the Hanoi Hilton probably
needed group therapy after John was
finished with them in addition to those
two former presidents Obama and George W
Bush former President Bill Clinton will
also be here today along with former
Vice President Al Gore and Dick Cheney
and another former GOP presidential
nominee war hero and Senator Bob Dole
the McCain motorcade will make its way
here to the National Cathedral with a
brief pause at the Vietnam veteran
Memorial where Cindy McCain will lay
Reese to remember those who fell Elaine
Nancy Court is at Washington's National
Cathedral thank you